the search for a new house speaker is
still happening Congressman Jim Jordan
losing on the first vote for the gavl
and it's unclear if he has enough
support to get to the magic number which
is 2117 Congressman Jordan announcing
that a second vote will take place
tomorrow at 11:00 a.m. the guy who had
the job two weeks ago Congressman Kevin
McCarthy is speaking out and he's
blaming democrats for the chaos you had
every single Democrat along with eight
Republicans
vote to shut down one branch of
government that is why we're in the well
no no no no no no let's go back to how
it got here we wouldn't be here if every
single Democrat didn't vote with eight
Republicans to shut this place
down Greg that that to me is an
interesting take on while we're where we
are but would you would you have an
opinion on this you agree with Mr
McCarthy or have a I don't know if I
have an opinion I I kind of want Jim
Jordan win so maybe he might wear a
jacket but this I mean obviously given
what's been going on this feels really
small and Petty it just shows you that
petty politics is Immortal no matter
what happens this goes on we have bigger
fish to fry and by fish I mean Hamas so
I don't know
judge I was looking up the names of the
eight I'm so angry that we're even in
this situation at this point in time
with the Democrats and and McCarthy is
absolutely right the you McCarthy did
everything the Democrats predicted uh
you know the Republicans would shut down
the government and people in the
military wouldn't get that check now
we're in a situation where they need
their checks and now McCarthy kept the
government open and now the Democrats
are voting to get him out yeah it's
disgusting and everyone who was involved
in that Nancy mace Matt Gates all of
them were in this mess because of them
and Jim Jordan's great scalise is great
McCarthy was great I don't know what
they it it's Petty nonsense
Jesse you're asking me about the speaker
situation blame the Democrats for the
situation we're in right now now that's
what you call Brilliant framing you make
this about the
Democrat is it true yes it is
technically true all of the house
Democrats and eight Republicans shut
down the Congress now Congress has shut
down do you notice anything different no
has your life changed the Israelis can't
get the money they need can't get the
money I feel like the Israelis are going
to get the money and are why would you
say that what do you mean
Greg advice of council I'd like to go to
dat well I would say where's the problem
solvers caucus when you need them this
is a problem that you would think needs
solved and they have lots of Democrats
that could help solve it you see what
they said over the weekend they said
five to 10 of them would join with all
the Republicans to give Patrick M
McKenry The Limited power for the next
to to do well they may have to do it
tonight but it is not tomorrow but it's
amazing let me just let that right this
is not the Democrats Parliament if the
Democrats in majority they would choose
a speaker one more thing always the Dem
one more is up next let me write that
down hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else